joe biden your friend
our friend friend of the show he might
call in later
um he did a town hall the other day
and uh someone stood up and asked him
would you cancel
fifty thousand dollars in student loan
debt what was the quote that he said
kai he said i will not make that happen
he stood his ground here's the story
president joe biden shot down a proposal
to cancel fifty thousand dollars in
student loan debt
for every borrower despite the pressure
from leading democratic lawmakers
to do that obviously that's the bernies
of the world the aoc's the elizabeth
warrens
an audience member at a cnn town hall
told byden that student debt is quote
unquote
crushing her friends family and fellow
americans
we need student loan forgiveness beyond
the potential
ten thousand dollars your administration
has proposed she said
we need at least 50 grand minimum
will you be able to make that happen by
and responded i will not make that
happen
one sentence byness proposed cancelling
ten thousand dollars in student
loan debt as a part of the coronavirus
relief while democratic senators chuck
schumer and elizabeth warren
called on buying to cancel up to 50
grand in student loan debt
per bower borrower during tuesday's town
hall a couple days ago by and expressed
skepticism
about the idea of canceling the billions
of dollars of debt that people
who have gone to harvard yale and penn
referring to ivy league
institutions is that going to be
forgiven rather than the use
then use that money to provide for early
education for young children
who come across disadvantaged
circumstances biden said
so a lot of the concern with biden
was he he was going to go extreme he was
going to pander to the aoc's of the
world
he was going to he's going to cave he's
a puppet he's not going to you know
stand his ground he's spineless all the
sleepy joe
and he's like no i'm not going 50 grand
sorry
i'm not going to do it i'm i might give
you 10. i might
but i'm not going 50. lying in the sand
i'm not going to do it obviously the you
know the story
two weeks ago was aoc says no we need to
push them
we can't just settle for 10 grand we
need to push we need to push
seems like he's made up his mind do you
believe him tom you know i do
i i will say this i'm mad enough to say
that i underestimated him a little bit
and i'm impressed i'm impressed by his
actions here i'll judge him
on a per case basis but for this i think
it i think it takes strength
to flat out say to someone asking you
that question because the politician
always wants to validate them make them
feel good
yes i'll do whatever yes it's it's
complete bs i think it takes strength
and walk around he could say i'm
thinking about it we're considering i
came out and said no yeah
not gonna happen and i i applaud him for
that and a couple things number one
i i was i guess my biggest fear was that
he would be that puppet and he's showing
so far
that he's not he they they've completely
minimized the squad
and these radicals i mean these far left
he's basically saying i got no time for
you
here's my theory on this joe biden is
old school
he was a senator for 40 years all right
he's paid his dues he's not gonna
finally get in the big chair
and let these young punks who don't know
what they're talking about
who run on pure emotion who don't bring
any of the real
concepts of what america what made
america great into their arguments
i love the fact he's heismanning all of
them still
giving him the stiff arm great analogy
right there but you know he doesn't even
listen to him which is even better
and imagine what that's doing to them
it's minimizing them completely
and and now they're just sounding like
you know with crazy these young punks
yeah
speaking of young punks kai how you
doing over there buddy student loan debt
what are your thoughts on this
no i think uh i mean the first thing
that comes to my mind is why are we
letting universities off the hook okay
well
go deeper on that go ahead and have the
no exactly but but the kids have the
debt i mean they knew what they're
that what they're going into you don't
look it's not like they're all hidden
costs i mean you see very clearly
i remember when i was looking at schools
i saw very clearly like tuition
semester xyz and you're like all right
you're doing two
semesters a year times four years and
you can crunch the numbers pretty
quickly um
so i think if anything if we're trying
to limit
limit student debt you should go after
the universities that are hiking up
these
educations where you're paying i don't
know 20 30 grand a semester for a zoom
college i don't i don't see that like
well i mean look at the
what does harvard have in their uh in
their harvard fund what is it called
endowment and their endowment hundreds
of billions and billions of dollars
where they could
pay for every harvard student the next
probably tens of years
and somehow they still need that money
just laying around there
and they're charging full price even
though nobody's on school at school
so i mean i think that's what i think is
outrageous that we're accepting
that they're can just charge these
astronomical fees without even thinking
oh and then the question is well we need
to forgive the student debt from the
from the from the people the students
coming there but it's like no
first of all you know what you're
getting into second of all why aren't we
turning the the lens of focusing on the
schools why the hell are you
uh charging this tuition like what are
they actually getting for this tuition
and
why is it so high and i think those are
the two bigger questions rather than
looking at what you're going to do
another interesting study uh which was
done by university
of chicago a working paper published
monday by the university of chicago
becker friedman institute for economics
show that
erasing all student debt would distribu
uh
would distribute 122 billion
uh to the top 20 earners in the u.s
but just 29 billion to the bottom 20
of us say those numbers one more time
please um if they're gonna if they're by
forgiving the
love student that uh they would 192
billion would go to the top 20 percent
top 20 earners in the us and just 29
would go to the bottom 20 percent so the
rich would get richer as well
the rich would would get less they would
get more debt
race because they have bigger loans of
course you're going to harvard you're
going to go
and the percentage of them are more in
grad school exactly so here's the
question guys because we i want to
i want to cover a couple of topics
what's the number is it 10 it's clearly
not 50 is it zero
what number are you comfortable with
erasing why is he doing it at all i mean
zero no bailout whatsoever where does it
okay
thank god he said no to wiping it all
away because there'd be no such thing as
death
anymore what about car loans what about
mortgages what about credit card debt
everybody would be up
incredibly slippery slopes so look i
don't think you want to
that's not his job is to to finally
become president and then just figure
out what debt loads he can wipe away
so i would say well especially when
you're adding more stimulus 1.9
proposals
imagine just the the truth what's what's
the current student loan debt 1.5
trillion mario you want to
1.8 1.8 is it that high now how do you
even manage this
you know as far as wiping away this
these loans and the percentages and
it would be an absolute nightmare so
kudos to him
mario aguilar what's the number 1.7
1.7 kai you've been like one point
off on every like bob barker would be
very upset with you right now you're
like one you're you're a little over on
everything this is what it is
paul's car what you got kyle would be
going to the showcase showdown for us
i think i had a point uh but i want to
go further on kai's point i i think
again they're trying to solve maybe the
student loan debt but
really there is an opportunity for the
country to make more money
and we all are our free market
capitalist here
um but they should change the tax
bracket of universities instead of you
can charge whatever you want cool but
now you're paying taxes
they they've been you know protected by
the government
and don't pay taxes but they can charge
whatever you want well
there's a little bit of a a math problem
wrong there so
i think reversing that would actually
solve more problems you'd
increase the revenue of our country and
be able to afford all that and then
people can pick and choose whether they
want to go there
and again give them more of that plus
they could use they could earmark some
of that tax money to take care of
ten thousand dollars or ten percent of
this debt you can actually pay for its
own property
a big part of it as well is like you
have i i get that
schools if you're just thinking like
class and this that the other that
they're that they're not taxed but you
have schools
that have major football teams you have
major baseball teams
all these other sports teams where
they're mostly major football and
basketball yeah where they have arenas
that are housing like thousands of
people where they're charging for the
tickets they're charging for sales of
jerseys or
what have you food anything like that
and on top of that they have major tv
contracts and all of this they're
funneling money in
and and they're still not taxed that
doesn't make sense either
so bottom line we agree with biden on
this we thumbs up or thumbs down on
biden's decision to stand his ground
you said thumbs up yes stand his ground
hundred percent ground yeah thumbs up on
this
it's a bonus thumbs up positive in his
book look joe biden getting thumbs up
i love paul's idea though seriously my
daughter just graduated from college
last year and she got completely robbed
because she wasn't able to experience
the final months she she couldn't even
have a graduation
yeah they should cut a check and pay
some of the money back to the parents
that's not what we signed up for that's
not you know what i mean especially a
school like she went to pepperdine
where the graduation is on a cliff
overlooking the ocean it's an incredible
experience
and she got robbed probably the only
pepperdine class that wasn't able to do
it
yeah college is man it it's changing
if you watch what's going on it is
changing it needs to
affect the actual universities though
because it's starting to affect the big
college football programs
they're giving the football players more
leeway you know it used to be total
control by these coaches they make five
million dollars and they're just
dictators
now if you if you're not happy where you
are you can enter this transfer portal
so you can essentially just leave if
you're a college football player college
coaches are freaking out
i think the same thing will happen with
chancellors if they start
saying hey look you know we're gonna
take a good look at this gravy train
that you've created for yourself here
creating all your own rules you're
responsible for educating these kids
which a lot of people aren't in favor of
your
your methods right now i would love for
them to take a big big look at it
because there's a lot of money there
that could be going in other directions
great word gravy train i like that word
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye